so what I want to do here is take the
next several weeks to cover the death
and return of Superman and what I'm
hoping is that at the end of all this
you'll have a strong understanding of
the story going into future discussions
but also have a grasp of why people feel
so strongly about it and why some say
that it destroyed death and comics
so the death of Superman was actually a
long time running and has its roots and
as early as 1971 what I mean here is
that during my series on Superman
leading up to crisis on Infinite Earths
we had talked about how the debut and
introduction of his character in 1939
assured in a new era for print media
prior to this stories involving
fictional content largely existed in
three forms written novels both long and
short pulp magazines and newspaper
strips where novels are pretty
straightforward
classic stories like Robinson Crusoe
Gulliver's Travels and even earlier
writings like Homer's epic Odyssey and
Dante Alighieri --zz Divine Comedy
helped us set the standard for defining
the classical definition of good versus
evil
likewise pulp magazines and newspaper
strips were themselves influenced by
these classical works and many of
superman's precursor themes and
characters like Doc Savage
Zorro and the Phantom detective were
instrumental in influencing the
designers to Grant himself regarding the
superhero archetype as such when he
first appeared in Action Comics issue
number one began the Golden Age and
created the comic book superhero as we
know it today the varying spin-offs like
Batman Captain America and others embody
the very essence of what Superman stood
for battling the forces of villainy and
saving the day however as the Golden Age
of comics began to wane in various
titles were met with cancellation
Superman remained a popular character
due to the fact that he was the original
comic superhero but also had a Superboy
publication under the creation of Jerry
Siegel and Joe Shuster which kept in
popular among younger boys and kept him
afloat amidst the rising popularity of
science fiction and so in DC editor
Julius Schwartz orchestrated the
unofficial reboot of the DC Universe in
1956 by introducing Barry Allen as the
flash he alongside Mort Weisinger began
the process of expanding on their
flagship character by adding something
new to the Superman landscape every six
months to this end between 1959 and 1971
the Superman comics expanded to include
two solo series one for Lois Lane and
one for Jimmy Olsen but also saw the
introduction of Supergirl the very super
animals including Krypto betta the
monkey and comet the horse but also
expanded on the role of Superboy in
providing batch stories that explain the
existence of Superman's most prom
villains like Lex Luthor in terms of why
he hated the Man of Steel so much the
result was that by the time 1971 rolled
around Superman was a hero with
astronomical strength vulnerable only to
the varying forms of kryptonite as well
as magic had a whole host of abilities
ranging from one-off powers like super
mathematics to main state powers like
super hearing and x-ray vision and so to
top DC's Pantheon as the most popular
hero in their lineup and so when more
Weisinger retired and Julius Schwartz
returned to oversee Superman's comics
Schwarz operated under the belief that
Superman was too powerful and kryptonite
existed as a plot device using this as a
basis a little swath was cut through all
of Superman's publications his powers
were reduced by one-half kryptonite was
removed entirely and his spacefaring
adventures were replaced with battles
against street-level criminals however
were Schwartz had hoped that this would
humanize the hero in the eyes of
attention fans the existing reader base
hated the idea and that to them
Superman's legacy was larger than life
and that his stories needed to reflect
this by providing battles against
larger-than-life villains now at the
same time that this was happening DC had
established their multiverse in 1961
using it as a means to explain the
sudden disappearance of the Golden Age
heroes of Jay Garrick and Alan Scott and
their replacement by Barry Allen and Hal
Jordan respectively what this meant was
at the door had been blown off its
hinges regarding the possibilities of
alternate reality counterparts to
Superman and by 1985 with crisis on
Infinite Earths the DC landscape had a
multitude of alternate universe versions
of Superman as well as their various
other characters but they had also
created a veritable witch's brew of
continuity issues with new fans having
no clue where to start or where exactly
he fit in regarding any particular
storyline and so following crisis on
Infinite Earths and the reconciliation
of all the alternate universes their
removal from existence for the most
popular characters being folded into the
main continuity referred to as new earth
the Superman series was taken over by
writer John Byrne who spent the next
three years
effectively retelling Superman's stories
and providing a new foundation for his
character the drawback to this was that
because of Schwartz's actions in the
1970s the dedicated Superman reader base
had effectively abandoned this series
and where the possibility existed in
terms of the return the continuity
reboot
crisis on Infinite Earths left a bad
taste in their mouth due to the fact
that is signified the idea that the
Superman they knew would never come back
to this end the field was left open for
another hero to step into the limelight
as DC's top character which came to
fruition by way of Frank Miller's a dark
knight allowing Batman to overtake
Superman in terms about popularity and
sales the result was that for five years
between 1987 and 1992
Superman continually slipped in
relevance with fans preferring the
darker and grittier stories of Batman
and so faced with this fact and the
summer of 1991 during their annual
summit DC brought in the writers and
artists of the Superman Line and it
never defined a way to restore his
character to relevance however the issue
the DC face was that in a lot of ways
people viewed the stories of Superman as
archaic and that the world had changed
and even if it still held a place in the
hearts and minds of some most
individuals didn't identify themselves
as someone who always did the right
thing and always made the right call
instead people recognized the
contradictory nature of humanity and the
fact that our words don't always match
our actions but because Superman's rigid
stance of a hero fighting villains was
virtually unshakable and the core of
what made him who he was the idea was to
introduce a story that will return into
relevance without destroying his legacy
during a 2014 interview with Andrew
steinbier of comic book calm Death of
Superman writer Dan Jergens had stated
that the initial idea as it had been
designed at the summit was to finally
bring Clark Kent and Lois Lane together
by having the two get married where John
Byrne's 1987 story Superman the secret
revealed provided the long-awaited
revelation to Lois that Clark and
Superman were one in the same since his
introduction in 1939 the two had never
been married before as a result at the
conclusion of a year-long buildup DC
intended to have Superman reveal his
identity to Lois with marriage coming
out of the decision however during this
time Lois and Clark the New Adventures
of Superman
was already in production and as a
byproduct of the deal worked out between
DC's parent company Warner Brothers and
ABC DC Comics and ABC had to work
jointly to ensure that neither produced
content that would disrupt the flow of
the other to this end when DC announced
their intention to have Lois and Clark
marry ABC had the company hold off since
there was an idea they enjoyed and could
actually make more money on their end
with
then DC could through their comics and
so in the years way the story's being
thrown out the window
DC went back to the drawing board in
order to find another way to make
Superman relevant during this time as
one of the long-standing members of
Superman's Summit miner Jerry Ordway had
always ended his meetings with the team
by making this statement let's just kill
him but because the writers for the
Superman stories were irritated at the
time regarding their inability to write
the story they had spent so long working
on rather than dismissing Jerry's
comments as nonsense instead the idea
stuck and the decision was made to write
the death of Superman following this the
focus of the creative team was split
into four ideas craft a story that
provided an unshakable finality create a
villain that could actually kill
Superman provide the story of how it
happened and answer the most important
question what happens after - the first
because Superman had been in existence
for almost 60 years at the time
virtually every story that could be
written had already been done Superman
had already revealed his identity to
Lois Lane
he had battled Darkseid on several
occasions he'd time traveled and he
attempted to stop his planets
destruction as a result because comics
like 1961's
issued 149 by Jerry Siegel and Curt Swan
had already killed Superman the creative
team was Anna boy who cried wolf
situation in the fans had already heard
this story before and so in order to
ensure that it would sell the creative
team needed to write the story in a way
which led people to believe that not
only was Superman gone but there existed
no indication that he would ever come
back and after the second task for
writer dan Jergens the biggest problem
regarding the death of Superman wasn't
how the story would be written but who
it was that would kill him because most
of his villains were largely modeled
after Lex Luthor in at they Chow and
Superman mentally rather than physically
the only person capable of going
toe-to-toe against the Man of Steel
without external aid would have been
Darkseid however Jergens wanted to
introduce a new villain that could be
used to kill Clark off without having to
fill lingering potholes and then if
Darkseid had killed Superman and lived
the question would be asked as to what
happens next regarding his character and
potential conquest of Earth
however if Darkseid died fighting
Superman then fans would have wanted to
know how the landscape of apocalypse
would change and so looking to bypass
this problem Durin's created dooms
a as a character that could eliminate
the possibility of lingering plot lines
by killing off Superman and dying in the
process however simply creating doomsday
and throwing him into the story couldn't
be done overnight and an event of this
magnitude needed to kind of build up in
order to achieve the effect that DC was
looking for the reason why is because
despite his lack of sales Superman
signified the greatness of humanity and
that as the father of the modern
superhero was literally the foundation
by which all other heroes had been built
on to this end doomsday needed to
function as the antithesis to Superman
and that he could be devoid of emotion
and concerned for the well-being of
others represent a fundamental force of
nature that couldn't be reasoned with
and bring life to the idea the Superman
had finally encountered a beam then we
couldn't overcome and so a month before
the death of Superman and within the
pages of Man of Steel issue number 17
Superman number 73 Adventures of
Superman number 496 and Action Comics
number 683 DC had Louise Simonson among
others continue the trend of Clark
fighting as various foes but at the end
of each comic a green cloth armed with
bones protruding could be seen punching
its way through a metal box culminating
in Man of Steel issue number 18 with a
first on page appearance of doomsday
having said that I want to transition
now to the origin of doomsday covered
with another three-part series titled
Superman doomsday hunter prey which was
written by Jan Jergens and drawn by
Brett breeding this particular story
comes out of the events of the death of
Superman because the story was so
popular with fans looking to see how it
was doomsday came into existence the
series follows up after Superman's
return with doomsday haunting his dreams
as the one villain that seemingly killed
him traveling to the Nexus of all
reality Superman looks to seek out
individuals who refer to as the linear
man now within the context of DC Comics
the linear man served as a general title
for a group of men and women who served
to eliminate paradoxes in the space-time
continuum and ensure that the continuity
flowed without interruption to its
completion which was usually presumed to
be the end of all things however because
they dealt directly with time itself
this afforded Clark the opportunity to
literally view the past and discover the
origin of doomsday so that he could find
a way to finally defeat him what we're
told is that in the early year
of Krypton's formation and around
250,000 years before the arrival of
Superman's race the planet existed as a
harsh environment with unpredictable
weather and savage animals during this
time the planet was visited by a
scientist named Bertrand and alongside
his live assistants and tended to grow
an infant through vitro fertilization
and subjected to the harsh environment
for the purpose of forcing it to
continually die and adapt now during a
conversation with his lab techs Bertrand
reveals that the singular basis behind
his actions as for the purpose of
creating a wildly powerful being who can
effectively withstand any fight and can
be used by Bertrand to place himself at
the peak of existence by using doomsday
as a weapon against his foes and so in
his first experiment the infant is sent
to the environment of Krypton
unprotected during which time it's
almost immediately spotted by the
various animals and attacked the result
is that in only two short seconds the
infant is completely torn to shreds and
presumably consumed by the animals
although this is never really confirmed
however one of the scientists is sent
out to retrieve some of the remaining
tissue which can be used to clone the
infant and begin the process a second
time now what's interesting about this
is that within the realm of genetics
this isn't unheard of
while we as humans only have a limited
understanding in terms of its full
potential we do know that the genes of
an organism are the byproduct of its
parent organisms and that those genes
effectively serve to provide the best
chance of survival within the context of
its ecosystem what Dan Jergens is doing
here is applying this concept to
doomsday and telling us that the purpose
of Bertrand continually subjecting the
infant to the harsh environment of
Krypton watching it die collecting his
tissue and then cloning it again meant
that the experience of how it died and
how to adapt to that particular instance
will continually live on within each
organism building up like a pyramid
until it reached its final form indeed
what the entrance tells us is that when
the baby was released in the environment
if it wasn't killed by the Predators in
the area it would die from any number of
other factors all within a matter of
moments and one instance the heat of the
environment would literally cook it from
the inside out and another instance the
skin would adapt to the heat where the
lungs would be unable to handle the
extreme pressure and would burst and so
each time the infant died and was
reclone it would become immune to each
of these causes and so that after 30
years of the cycle
of death and rebirth the infant was
finally able to remain outside for only
several hours where the infant did die
during its encounter with the Predators
this particular instance was a good
indication of Bertrand's work in that
the baby was developing both the
knowledge and physical attributes
necessary to ensure its survival meaning
that after an unspecified amount of time
the infinite managed to survive on the
planet for two years growing into a
fully functional adult form however the
failure of Bertrand comes into full view
when we realized that because the
process had taken so long he gave no
thought to what would happen when
doomsday was advanced enough to survive
and eliminate all the organisms on the
planet furthermore because the
experiments of Bertrand saw all the
previous forms of doomsday dying leading
up to his current form doomsday came to
the belief that Bertrand himself along
with all of his ilk were an enemy that
needed to be eliminated to ensure its
own survival and so breaking his way
into the facility doomsday killed
Bertrand and all the scientists within
their own base of operations
owing to the fact that because he had
been designed to withstand and adapt to
any circumstance he had quite literally
become Frankenstein's monster and that
Bertrand could not control or stop him
and so following this because Bertrand
operated in isolation and away from
other beings with the exception of his
staff a series of supply drops were
commissioned to ensure that Bertrand had
the supplies he needed without being
bothered during his experiments however
the condition of these supply jobs was
that no contact would be made and
instead they would simply show up drop
off what was needed and leave as a
result when the supply ship arrived
doomsday hitched a ride allowing him to
escape the planet now from here jurgis
doesn't really give us a play-by-play of
Doomsday's exploits and in truth we
don't really need it given that this
story took place after the death of
Superman the format ability of doomsday
spoke for itself and so instead Jurgen
simply tells us the doomsday would
arrive on a planet kill everything over
the course of several years escape and
continue the pattern across the universe
now to be clear doomsday is not in and
of himself a highly intelligent being
instead he's largely governed by his
instincts which drive him to kill all
life and where he's not smart enough to
physically pilot a vessel he is smart
enough to stow away on one
we're Jergens doesn't tell us exactly
how he travelled from world to world I
would surmise that whenever he had
hacked her world its occupants will put
up a fight
realized they were outmatched and flee
during which time doomsday would stow
away on a vessel kill its inhabitants
and start the process again when he
arrived on the new world as it was
programmed by the ship's navigation but
regardless of the intricacies of how he
moved throughout the cosmos the fact
remains that his actions drew the
attention of a race called the
Caledonians as a group that had predated
the Kryptonians and were the most
technologically advanced race at the
time within three years after his
arrival
doomsday had laid waste to all but the
capital of their society and so because
the royal family had begun the early
stages of metahuman development the
decision was made to bring the royal
family together who would sacrifice
their powers losing their lives in the
process for the sake of creating an
artificial life-form known as the
radiant which could battle doomsday and
a fight that took over a week from start
to finish the essence of Doomsday's
ability to recover from death came to
fruition when the radiant had bombarded
him with energy attacks something
doomsday had never experienced before
because the remaining members of the
Catalonian society maintained their
burial rituals not unlike humanity the
decision was made to lock doomsday away
in a block of metal and sent him
careening into space destined to drift
for eternity however during the process
Doomsday's vessel came into contact with
an asteroid field during which time he
was thrown off course where it landed on
earth and remained buried underground
for over two hundred thousand years with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end and next week we'll
begin the process of actually getting
into the Death of Superman proper
without being said I will catch you guys
later peace